はじめしゃちょーです。
僕は今日この企画を確かめたくて
僕は今回これをしたくて頑張って確かめました。
今回僕はこのぎゃくｔ...僕今回ふぁ〇きゅー！！！
今回僕この企画をしたくて頑張ってためました、こちら
（バラバラバラ）
(ジュルルル)みんな大好きiTunesカードです。
iTunesカード。これ何かといいますとスマホでですねいろいろあるじゃないですか。
音楽・アプリまぁその他いろいろあるんですけども、
例えばこれです。
これ5000円って書いてあるんですけど、これ5000円分。
5000円分のアプリとかゲーム・ミュージックとか映画とかブックを買うことが出来るというやつです。
わっはちょっと待ってめっちゃ買ったなーw
あ、僕だけじゃないですけどね。
これ全部実は使用済みなんですけど僕とか友達のiTunesカードを僕が頑張って集めて、
なんとかこの量のiTunesカードをゲットしたんですけども、
いや、めちゃくちゃあります。
何円分？
えっと51000...52500円.....
52500円⁉️
今からですねとあるYouTuberが僕ん家に遊びに来るんですけども、
そのYouTuberね
なんか結構、真面目っぽいんですよ。
結構、真面目というか
で、さっき事前に聞いたらやっぱスマホのゲームいろいろやってるみたいです。
デュエルリンクスとかシャドバとか
多分ねiTunesカード見たら...
うっ、、、、、
血が騒ぐんすよ
課金...
課金したい...
アプリに課金したい…
アプリに課金したい！
ふるるるるるwww
iPhoneでスマホゲームしてる人は
iTunesカード見たら課金したくなってしまいます。
これは病気です。
今回初めてそいつ今から僕ん家に来るんですけども、
もし僕が留守にして一人で僕んちにいたときにその僕のいる部屋に大量のiTunesカードがあったり、
いろんな場所に隠されてたりしたら、
今回その実験をやってみようと思います！
もう欲望との闘い
多すぎるから1個くらい使っても大丈夫かな？
先っぽだけならいいでしょ。（エロい意味じゃないよ）
そういう感覚で事件は起きてしまうんです。
iTunesカードを全部僕のある部屋に隠して、ターゲットを１人その部屋において、
果たして！まぁ使わないようなタイプだとは思うんですけど、
やっぱ人間欲に負けちゃうんで、使わないのか使っちゃうのかをちょっと検証してみたいと思います。
僕なら使います。
では隠していきます！
はい、というわけで不自然なくらいにiTunesカードをまき散らしておきました。
これなら多分誘惑に負けると思います。
間違いない！だからきっとこれで彼は
１枚くらいならばれないでしょという甘～い気持ちで使ってしまい、
多分こっそり使うんじゃないかなと思っております。
では！
はじめ「うわ、やば！うわぁ。ガチ、ガチ…」
imiga「いや、ガチじゃないよ。全然ガチじゃないから、本当。」
はじめ「あ、やべえ、終わった。終わったわ。」
はじめ「ちょっとコンビニ行ってくるね、すぐ戻ってくるから」
imiga「やっぱりあったこいつww」
wwwwwwwwwwww
はじめ「さ、どういう落とし方にしようか。」
imiga「オチが…」
はじめ「難しいね。」
はじめ「じゃあ、ミガチが一個スキャンして…」
はじめ「反応しないんだよ多分。使われてますって出るから。」
はじめ「それでじゃあ、チッ(舌打ち)って舌打ちして終わろう。
imiga「あ、OK」
imiga「ﾁｯ(舌打ち)」